(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Чудово.
Так, тоді базові даних, ми цю проблему говорили.
Ми тоді розглянемо більш детальніше в п'ятницю,
які є проблеми.
У нас, мені здається, заняття там на 11
.20 буде, так?
Якщо я не помиляюсь.
Так, у нас заняття на 11.20. Можемо
глянути, в чому проблеми є, і виберемо.
Загалом, які ще є проблеми, чи загальний прогрес
по проекту?
Ну, загалом, ми додали ще три сторінки, і
поки що все.
Все інше це вже з базами зав'язано.
Анкети і реєстрація.
Тобто, новини треба ще додати, поки що це
просто пусті сторінки.
І товари.
І товари додати ще треба.
І в мене ще є таке питання.
Дивіться, ми підідаємо базу даних для того, щоб
була реєстрація на сайті, так?
Так.
Тобто, щоб можна було і вийти в аккаунт
оптології, і реєстрація саме, що повинна була.
Тобто, щоб дві окремих форми було, так?
Так, ну, тут загалом, як ви хочете зробити,
можна і це все вмістити в одну форму,
просто натискати кнопку, чи це кодити, чи реєструватися.
А так, ну, загалом, вам потрібно буде зберігати
хоча б дані по користувача.
Я не впевнений…
Тобто, це пароль, емейл і логін?
Ну, так, в залежності від того, що там
користувач буде вказувати, але так, мінімум хоча б
ось такий.
Можна, або м'я користувач, а навіть той
пароль.
Тобто, щось такого типу можна взяти.
Дивіться, я не впевнений, чи на модлі Сергій
Олексійович викладав записи для перегляду повторного заняття.
Я зараз, давайте, зайду гляну.
Так, я бачу, що тут є конспекти, я
бачу, зрозуміло.
Тому тут записів, наскільки я бачу, немає.
Я запитаю Сергія Олексійовича, але загалом так.
Ну, тобто, знову з базами даних така.
Приклад того підключення я вам можу також завантажити
п'ятницю на GitHub.
Скинути посилання прикладу того, що я розробляв на
заняттях, як приклади.
Тобто, щоб у вас був, знаєте, вже готовий
сервер, і ви там собі брали частини і
змінювали під свої потреби.
Думаю, що це буде найадекватніший варіант.
Загалом, я вам можу і зараз його надіслати.
Якщо ви хочете глянути, то...
Ось, я надіслав чаті.
Можете глянути загалом до п'ятниці, а п
'ятницю можемо вже детально розглянути.
Але загалом можете повністю копіювати те, що тут
є, хоча б з прикладом бекенду і підключенням
до бази даних.
Звісно, тут дуже загальний я робив приклад, а
ви там вже можете під'єднувати до своїх
потреб.
Тому, я думаю, що це буде найпростіший варіант.
Думаю, п'ятницю також всім іншим скину, і
ви можете колегам відправити.
Добре, дивіться, ще там питання.
У нас просто на сайті є така сторінка,
як анкета.
Я так правильно розумію, це ж це реєстрація
має бути, чи це просто типу як анкета?
Це вас анкета на те, щоб вступити.
Це просто анкета, це не реєстрація.
Все, зрозумів.
Наскільки я пам'ятаю, там типу анкета була,
щоб вступити в корпорацію, але як користувачі, мені
здається, можна було реєструватися.
Ну, взагалі, можете підіймати і також просто додавати
дані, і все.
Ну, зберігати там всі ті дані, які користувач
лишає, і на цьому зупинитися.
Я думаю, що там є потреба дуже якось
розширено її реалізовувати.
Ну, подивлюся в ваш приклад, я бачу так,
що у вас тут html є.
Ну, так, там повний приклад того, що ми
робили.
Ну, з backend, backend там index.js. Можете
глянути, там такі дуже загальні приклади.
Ну, і не забувайте, що для того, щоб
під'єднати їх до MongoDB, вам треба дозволити
IP-адресу своїм.
Ну, але загалом, розглянемо все ж таки в
п'ятниці.
Тобто, якщо ви хочете, можете почекати, якщо ні,
то можете глянути те, що тут є в
репозиторії, і спробувати поглянути, чи зможете щось робити.
Але в п'ятницю, якщо будуть якісь проблеми,
то можемо тоді оглянути.
Ну, і в нас тоді останнє заняття з
вами на наступному тижні в п'ятницю.
Це 9.30, це буде в нас презентація
проєктів.
Насправді, наскільки я пам'ятаю, правильно.
Ну, і останнє сентап у нас буде також
на наступному тижні.
Тому треба підготувати проєкти, щоб вони вже були
в тому вигляді.
І також не забувайте, що вам треба буде
їх завантажити і backend, і frontend на відповідні
сервера, щоб інші також могли зайти.
Сервери це на GitHub, ви маєте на увазі?
Так, і рендер.
Ми також розглядали.
Ну, backend на рендер там досить легко.
Ви просто під'єднуєте GitHub-репозиторій, і воно
все автоматично робить.
І з GitHub-у ще малу частину можна
завантажити за допомогою GitHub-пейджес.
Але це вже будуть такі остаточні моменти.
Я думаю, що зараз...
Розібратися з базою даних там потрібно.
Так.
Тому поки що з тим намагайтесь розібратись.
Ну і там вже будете дивитись стосовно того,
що встигати будете.
Добре.
Розумімо.
Чи ще є тоді якісь запитання?
Ну так, поки немає.
Буду сидіти.
Поки ще немає, так.
Розбиратись.
Добре.
Стосовно п'ятниці.
Чи були якісь ідеї стосовно того, щоб хотіли
додатково побачити?
Ну поки від нашої команди, напевно, поки ні.
Другій команді ми передали.
Може в них буде щось, не знаю.
Поки мовчать.
Добре.
Ну, поки що планом будемо розглядати пагінацію.
Зробити там посторінковий, наприклад, як інтерфейс.
Простий.
І загалом з цього будемо пробувати щось робити.
Не знаю, мені було б цікаво, наприклад, типу,
якийсь, як це правильно сказати, існує ще якийсь
бистрий адаптив сайту.
Ну, щоб не робити там, наприклад, дуже багато
медіазапросів, щоб, ну там, наприклад, при такій пікселізації
такі класи там будуть зменшуватись, а якось це
улегшує якісь адаптації сторінок.
Ви маєте на увазі під мобільні версії і
все таке?
Мобільні, так, так, оце планшети, зменшувати, ну, цікаво.
На жаль, якщо ви використовуєте щось типу Bootstrap,
то там вже є готові класи, які, загалом,
прописані мобільні розрахунки.
Але якщо розробляєте чисто з використаннями HTML та
CSS, то там потрібно, звісно, власноруч це робити.
Я зрозумів.
Але у вас, загалом, немає потреби на ваші
проекти, хоча б робити якісь на телефони, тут
ми розраховуємо течіну.
Ні, я розумію, я просто для власного досвіду.
Цікаво було.
Добре, ну, я можу це оглянути.
Ми можемо трошки зачепити це на занятті, якщо
будемо встигати.
Тоді в п'ятницю, ну, будемо дивитись по
часу.
Якщо ми встигнемо, то я буду намагатися охопити
і частину з тим, як робити дизайни під
телефон.
Дякую.
Ну, і все, тоді в нас більше немає
нічого такого.
Добре, тоді...